whatever it takes yeah so normally I do
not release videos this late in the day
normally it's early well or morning my
time I have a pretty set schedule and
I'd also said I was gonna do fewer
videos and not as many quick turnaround
reactions except that I actually do want
to talk about this one
so Avengers end game went dropped
another trailer a little bit
unexpectedly there hadn't really been
and I like if there were rumblings that
it was happening at all I missed them
and they didn't do their usual build-up
of announcing that they were going to
announce the date that the trailer drops
you know that kind of nonsense that
tends to go on none of that happened
here in hindsight we kind of should have
expected this to happen that they would
drop a trailer which would basically
debut Captain Marvel in Avengers endgame
which this does so I'm loving this
entire approach to the way they are
advertising and marketing this movie so
that is worth pointing out that the word
is and this is this unconfirmed because
generally and anyone who's seen any of
the like preview or you know early you
know tests anything like that they're
all under pretty strict you know
non-disclosures and all that but the
word that's kind of filtered through
from all that is that there isn't
anything shown into any of these
trailers not even this later one that is
from any later than the first half hour
of the movie and if that's true
oh that makes me so happy right honestly
if I had control of Hollywood I would
write that into the laws of movie
marketing that you do not show anything
what my hardline would be more than
halfway into the movie but more than a
half hour to the movie yes if you can't
pull enough out of the first half-hour
to sell me on the movie then you know
what that to me says I'm gonna be bored
for the first half of the movie anyway
and I don't want to see it so I
I love that now that said I don't want
to overpraise this movie for doing that
because part of the reason that this
movie can get away with that is because
this movie has a heck of a lot more just
established understanding of what it is
and so there isn't as much fear from the
studio from the markers although Disney
hasn't usually been as bad about that as
some other studios have been sony has
been pretty bad Warner Brothers has been
bad at at some points in the past
Fox actually was awful at times and in
regards to this sort of thing
Disney is not Disney and Marvel are not
the worst offenders as far as this kind
of thing tends to go but even taking
that into account I'm pretty sure they
wouldn't be doing it if this was not a
case of it's a movie they're pretty much
guarantee everyone's gonna see anyways
so they have that backing and they also
don't really have to establish anything
I mean like anybody who saw infinity war
knows the deal they know they know what
the goal is gonna be the goal is gonna
be to undo what they knows did is did
and they know the stakes so you don't
have to reestablish any of that because
anyone who has no clue what's going on
in this at this point they didn't watch
the last movie in which case this
movie's gonna have nothing for them
anyway because it's such a direct
follow-up that there'd be no point
seeing this if you hadn't seen infinity
war and it doesn't hide but it doesn't
pretend that that is not the case which
I love as far as the trailer itself you
know Tate is setting aside the overall
general feel and vibe to the marketing
which again I love this is again banking
on some older material which some of the
other trailers have also done and that
would have run the risk of starting to
get old except they didn't recycle old
audio this time they did recycle some
old video but honestly there was
something about going monochrome with
only the red popping through that I
really kind of enjoyed I there's
something about that that get that gave
it a little extra something and made me
not mind the recycling of old footage in
order to give us something to look at
other than you know
spoiler stuff which is you know what I
would have been afraid of if they had
filled it out with all with footage from
the new film but I something about that
really works for me something about that
that monochrome with just the red poppy
and like the nature of what was red and
popping across the screen changes from
shot to shot to shop whether it's you
know just bits of Tony's arc reactor
whether it's just the red stripes on the
flag when we get Captain America whether
it's Thor's cape whether it's its
Falcons you know goggles big chunks of a
koi yays outfit or you know just these
tiny little slivers it's it's a nice mix
and I enjoy that a lot
so now moving on from that getting into
the new footage that we actually get so
we get uh we get kind of a
reestablishment of the characters that
we've already seen and the trailers up
to this point there's a few men in ajiz
I really like I really like rocket
hanging out a war machine shoulder I
don't know I never thought of the two of
them pairing off I actually like I kind
of love that and I really want to see
that now and I I like the intensity
that's going on with Natasha and also
with Steve a little bit that there's
he's got a little bit more of a twinkle
in his eye and some of the shots they
have from from this then he's had in
some of the other stuff which cool I'm
down with that
I I would say that the one thing that I
don't love I don't love these white and
red Avengers logo outfits that are all
striding in towards the end I doubt
they're gonna be in those for very long
for my money that stuff they have to put
on in order to basically go into space
and go after thinness for my money
that's why they're in those it's
basically you know the Avengers
equivalent of space suits because
there's no way they stay in those
because if for no other reason than
visually logistically it will be a
horrible idea
especially when the action scenes get as
intense as they can be in these movies
you need all these characters to be and
remain visually distinct from each other
so you know the costume is a pretty big
way of how that's done so you can't have
them all in the same outfit so I don't I
don't see that sticking
too long so as much as I don't love that
look like I doubt it'll be there for
very long I sort of love Hawkeye's hair
it just it looks dumb it yeah it's just
not a good look that's it I was really
intrigued by sort of the presumably it's
a flashback of him with his family and
it looks like teaching his daughter
archery and it's been the suspicion it's
not it's not confirmed in the chosen
it's not even really confirmed in this
one but there's something about the very
haunted look that he has in in the shots
where we get a good look at him that
says to me his family went in the snap
and it would also justify that flashback
being shown to give that a little bit
more more weight and more poignancy so
that would make a lot of sense
especially for how the trailer is
constructed and I'm yeah I'm just really
excited for this thing I and I might
like my hat goes off to this this entire
marketing approach it is doing such a
good job of speaking personally building
up hype while giving away nothing I
don't want it because I don't want to
know I don't want to know what's gonna
happen before I get into the theater but
I'm so excited to see this so and then
there's the tail end where we get
Captain Marvel in there and I like that
they don't give her like this big huge
hero shot which is and this is not
knocking what they did for the civil war
trailer but like to compare it to say
when they showed spider-man for the
first time in that civil war trailer
that was like a big hero highlighted
shot you know that they they ended it
with it it's sort of lingered it was
instantly you know giftable me mobile
all this stuff with with Carol's
appearance in in this trailer that's not
so much the case I kind of like that I
like that it's more subdued and I like I
like that she is maintaining that cool
calm collected thing I mean a my review
for
Captain Marvel is out and I did pretty
much like it I didn't love it but I did
enjoy it and I did like her what I
especially liked here is I liked it
under other circumstances the whole idea
of a character who has already been
around and we already know and love
saying I like her like to a new ish you
know new to the Avengers movies anyways
character like almost like it's a silly
rule like see audience you like her
because you like him and he likes her
like that under other circumstances
might have annoyed me and and struck me
as manipulative but there's something
about it yeah I think what it is is why
because I feel the reason it doesn't
feel manipulative to me here is because
I understand why he feels like that and
it feels true to the character which is
that Thor does a very Thor thing which
is he has this big kind of show off the
moment you know calling the axe to his
hand right by her head and she doesn't
flinch like her eyes just kind of and a
little smirk like otherwise no reaction
I think he's impressed by how
unimpressed she is and that to me and
like the fact that she gives that little
story she's not like just missing what
he did she's not like whatever she's
like oh okay so that so you do that
alright and I kind of like that he's
he's like all right you've seen stuff
you know what's up I like her and that's
why this moment works for me even though
on paper it's the sort of thing that
might have otherwise annoy me it's it's
executed just right to like get just in
there thread the needle and get the
sweet spot so that it works and doesn't
irritate me because it very easily could
have but didn't so again my only
complaints are tiny aesthetic things
like Hawkeye's hair and these what again
what I'm presuming our spacesuits but
other than that oh man when does this
thing come out is that a Brewers it may
whichever it is it's not soon enough
so Avengers end game latest trailer it's
out what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a bunch
stuff to do buttons links patreon
I'll buy wish list down there because
my birthday this month next week
actually hey so if you feel like get me
some of that off there best there this
Bo box we want to send me these stuff
that isn't on the wish list I promise
after the months over I will stop trying
to get people to send me free stuff but
that stuff's all down there if you want
to take a look at it and if you don't
that is okay too
because at the end of the day folks you
are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]